FOR THE WEEK THE DOW WAS DOWN,
1.5 PERCENTAGE POINTS, THE
S&P 500 DROPPED 1.2.
THE NASDAQ ONE POINT OFF.
THERE WERE NO SURVIVORS ABOARD
AN AIR FORCE SPECIAL OPERATIONS
HELICOPTER THAT CRASHED IN IRAQ,
WE TOLD YOU THAT FIRST ON
"SPECIAL REPORT."
THAT IS THE FIRST DEADLY
AVIATION ACCIDENT FOR U.S.
FORCES IN IRAQ OR SYRIA SINCE
THE BATTLE AGAINST ISIS BEGIN IN
2014.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
RESPONDING FROM THE PENTAGON
ABOUT A TOUGH WEEK FOR U.S.
MILITARY AVIATION AND THE
MILITARY.
>> THE AIR FORCE ON THE COPTER
CRASHED WHILE ON A ROUTINE
MISSION DURING PERSONNEL BETWEEN
BASES IN WESTERN IRAQ, ALL SEVEN
AMERICANS WERE KILLED.
INITIAL REPORTS SAY THAT THE
SPECIAL OPERATIONS HELICOPTER
HIT A POWER LINE NEAR THE CITY
OF AL KIME AMONG THE IRAQ, SYRIA
BORDER.
ONE DAY AFTER THE U.S. NAVY
SUPER HORNET CRASHED OFF OF
KEY WEST.
FLYING ON ONE ENGINE AS IT
APPROACHED THE RUNWAY AT LOW
ALTITUDE.
1 MILE OUT THE OTHER ENGINE
FAILED.
THE JET ROLLED OVER AS BOTH OF
THE AVIATORS WERE EJECTED
KILLING THE PILOT JAMES JOHNSON
AND HIS WEAPON SYSTEM OFFICER
CALEB KING WHO PLAYED FOOTBALL
AT THE NAVAL ACADEMY AND
GRADUATED IN 2012.
THE JET CAME FROM A SQUADRON
THAT DEPLOYED LAST YEAR ABOARD
USS GEORGE WH BUSH CARRYING OUT
AIR STRIKES AGAINST ISIS.
THE PENTAGON WOULD NOT SAY
WHETHER THE CRASH RESULTED FROM
YEARS OF COMBAT AND BUDGET CUTS.
>> READINESS IS AT THE CENTER OF
WHAT WE ARE DOING RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THAT PILOTS ARE GOING TO
BE FLYING MORE IN TRAINING IS
GOING TO PICK UP.
>> TODAY ONLY HALF OF THE NAVY
SUPER HORNET FLEET CAN FLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPOKE IN FRONT
OF AN F-18 AT A BOWLING HANGAR
IN MISSOURI HOURS AFTER THE
CRASH.
>> THE F-18, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLANES, IT IS A WORK OF ART.
>> THE 2018 DEPENDS BUDGET CALLS
FOR $48 BILLION TO REBUILD U.S.
AVIATION PARADE $11.7 BILLION TO
REPAIR OLD JETS, $32.5 BILLION
TO REPLACE JETS THAT CANNOT BE
REPAIRED.
$2.2 BILLION TO RECRUIT NEW